et on va plus loin avec aujourd'hui à
mes côtés désormais comme chaque mardi
marie roger biloa directrice d'africa
groupe international africa media group
merci d'être avec nous marie roger
virginie herz et également avec nous
chroniqueuse internationale sur france24
présentatrice du magazine actuel bonjour
virginie le courage a désormais un nom
marina offs yannick au va et un visage
celui de cette journaliste russe
reconnaissable derrière sa pancarte
brandie en plein jt du soir sur le
plateau de la chaîne la plus regardée à
cette heure de grande écoute le tout
pour dénoncer l'invasion de l'ukraine
par son pays un cri d' alerte lancée aux
téléspectateurs russes soumis au rouleau
compresseur d'une propagande désormais
omniprésente jugé en comparution
immédiate et les coques pour l'heure
d'une simple amende et recouvre sa
liberté ira-t-elle à l'ambassade de
france comme le lui suggérait manuel
macron le président français s'est dit
prêt à lui offrir l'asile écouter
ont lancé les démarches diplomatiques
visant à offrir une protection soit
l'ambassade soit aussi une protection
asilaire à votre confrère et j'aurai
l'occasion lors de mon prochain
entretien avec le président poutine 2
proposait d'ailleurs cette cette
solution de manière directe et très
concrètes comme je lé fais à chaque fois
je souhaite en tout cas que au plus vite
nous puissions avoir toutes toute clarté
sur sa situation personnelle et sa
capacité à poursuivre son travail le
chef de l'état qui s'exprimait avec vous
le voyez il ya lui marlène schiappa
alors qu'il visitait le centre de
réfugiés ukrainien de la pommeraie dans
le maine et loire emmanuel macron dit
vouloir proposer une solution à vladimir
poutine lors de leur prochaine
entretiens at il raison de le faire
marie roger biloa elle est désormais un
symbole elle pourrait où elle risque de
devenir demain martyrs et oui alors et
peut-être pas cette fois ci et c'est ça
qui est assez étonnant je crois que tous
ceux qui ont suivi cette scène à
l'étranger étaient terrifiés pour elle
mais le verdict est assez assez doux
puisque elle écope que de combien de 30
mille roubles d'amande et qu'elle est
déjà les bains 30000 euros à peu près
250 euros et qu'elle est déjà libéré
bon c'est vrai que l encours encore
peut-être une peine
mais je crois que c'est tout ça rentre
dans le cadre de cette propagande aussi
aux russes pour montrer que
contrairement à ce qu'on dit et ne sont
pas si méchant que ça que la presse
qu'on peut s'exprimer enfin il ya
beaucoup de conjectures mais celle là me
semble la plus probable parce que
dans toute guerre la première chose la
première victime commencé de la guerre
c'est la vérité ces informations et
c'est une arme hautement stratégique
donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait de marina est
ce qu'on en fait à une star est une
victime et un martyre où on essaie de
calmer le jeu et de est de faire croire
que c'est pas grand chose qui s'est
passé alors donc on verra bien ce que la
russie allait tôt rien faire on l'a
rappelé virginie marinov sannikova reste
en liberté elles n'en demeurent pas
moins menacé aujourd'hui c'est de voir
parce que là pour le moment elle a été
condamnée pour une vidéo qu'elle a
enregistrés juste avant son action
spectaculaire et postée sur internet on
disait qu'elle était contre la grêle
guerre en ukraine effectivement son
avocat craint qu'elles soient jugés pour
je cite publication d'informations
mensongères ce que vous vous rappelez
peut-être que depuis le 4 mars le
parlement russe a voté une loi qui qui
rend passibles de tout enfin qui rend
toute critique envers l'armée russe
passible d'une peine maximale de 15 ans
de prison effectivement peut-être que la
justice russe va attendre un petit peu
histoire qu'on passe à autre chose qu on
oublie la faire pour pas en faire tout
de suite un symbole parce que
effectivement son image et son geste ont
été ont été partagés dans le monde
entier mais ce qui est intéressant c'est
que dans les médias russes on n'en parle
pas ou quasiment pas et surtout ceux qui
en parlent la montre sans l'écriture du
panneau de l'écriture du panneau a été
agressé et ce qui est intéressant aussi
c'est que dans les systèmes
d'information verrouillé comme c'est la
russie ans comme les larges et en ce
moment il y a de temps en temps des des
graines de vous demander c'est quand
même difficile de maintenir une vérité
officielle dans un pays qui s'est ouvert
quand même durant 30 années à la une
forme de liberté d'expression c'est à
dire avant le verrouillage actuelle et
après le vol le bolchevisme il ya eu
quand même une période entre la chute du
rideau de fer et la période actuelle
durant laquelle il ya eu un semblant de
liberté d'expression en russie est ce
que c'est ce n'est pas difficile
aujourd'hui d'opérer ce retour en
arrière pour les russes d'abord c'est
même plus possible parce qu'on est un à
l'heure des réseaux sociaux tout a
changé le contexte a changé
officiellement quand même on est libre
de s'exprimer en russie officiellement
ils ne disent pas que la presse est
muselée
même si voilà les journalistes sont pas
si libre que ça il ya un mec qui sont
assassinés et mais en période de guerre
si tu verras hélas ce qu'on venait à
l'esprit en voyant ça c'est que même si
on essaie de bétonner on a eu et qu'on
veut présenter une vérité officielle et
le font avec beaucoup beaucoup
d'application et à ses méthodes je
repensais à l'irak en 2008 lorsque il y
avait aussi la propagande américaine sur
la guerre en irak ou
de george bush d'abdou
annoncé pensé qu'il allait être
accueillis avec des fleurs et tout était
présentée de manière assez aseptisé
jusqu'à ce que ce journaliste montaswin
ce qui s'appelait mountazar al zeidi en
2008 lance une pierre une chaussure gens
à
bouger ça tout le monde a été tranchée
dans le foie en turquie lors d'un sommet
du fmi
de voir en direct alors que vous pouvez
être sûr que la sécurité était assez
verrouillé donc il ya souvent des des
grains de sable comme ça qu'ils font
dérailler la vérité officielle et là
évidemment en russie c'est exactement le
cas mais toujours quand même beaucoup
faire de plus en plus les journalistes
ont quand même des difficultés et ça
fait maintenant ça fait dix ans que ça
dure la première loi répressive en
matière de liberté d'expression et de la
presse et en novembre 2012 donc il ya
dix ans exactement les premiers qui ont
été visés c'était des ong qui risquait
d'être c'était la loi contre les agents
de l'étranger donc les associations de
droits humains pouvaient être plus
indiquée pour être manipulé par les deux
jusqu'à un mémorial dernièrement
exactement cinq ans plus tard donc
c'était en 2017 c'est les médias qui
pouvait être jugé pour être agent de
l'étranger et maintenant depuis 2019 les
journalistes ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que depuis maintenant le début du
conflit plus de 140 journalistes ont été
détenus d'après reporters sans
frontières et plus de 150 journalistes
ont quitté la russie tout simplement
parce que c'est quasiment impossible à
part par des actes héroïques comme on
vient de voir deux communique il n'ya
pas qu'en russie un collectif d'une
menace
ukrainienne et occidentale contre la
sûreté russe la thèse en fête officielle
un défendu par moscou pour justifier
cette invasion fait des émules ce n'est
absolument pas ce que c'est un discours
c'est un narratif différent de celui de
l'occident en général c'est à dire que
on peut on essaye de dire voilà il a été
poussé dans ses retranchements
poutine n'a pas été assez entendu et ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que on a parlé
de censure du côté russe mais il ya
aussi activement de la propagande des
fakes news qui vont être relayé de façon
plus ou moins subtiles en russie mais
également en europe à travers de ce que
certains disent être des idiots utiles
et ça se transmet par télégramme par les
réseaux sociaux ont ont enfin certains
chercheurs qui travaillent sur ces
questions voit qu'il ya une sorte de
concomitance aussi avec les réseaux
enfin les groupes complotistes et donc
effectivement aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui beaucoup d'informations
circulent et c'est pour ça que c'est
très important que les médias fassent
régulièrement du tchèque news enfin
dollar vérification et démonte tout ce
système de de fait knut pas qu'en europe
1 qu'en est-il en afrique de l'ouest en
afrique centrale marie roger biloa dans
ses anciennes colonies françaises
courtisé par la russie soit du temps de
l'union soviétique soit aujourd'hui
comme on observe au mali en centrafrique
et bien c'est vrai c'est assez
intéressant qui se passe alors il ya une
perception africaine qui comme souvent
est faite de 8 et de réalité alors
parmi générer ce que les points forts ce
que les gens retiennent au crédit de la
russie il ya donc se passer son
implication dans la décolonisation je me
souviens d'un ambassadeur russe à paris
qui disait l'émancipation des peuples
voilà qu'il disait à paris il ne semble
être qu'un vous savez nous on n'a pas
participé à la colonisation mais on a
aidé à la décolonisation une belle
formule ce vin qui fait toujours mouche
dont il ya cette période là et aussi il
faut dire que à l'époque la russie
n'avait pas le visage
menaçant et répressive qui elle est
qu'elle a aujourd'hui mais c'était
plutôt les états unis parce que on se
souvient que des gens comme lumumba à
l'époque avait été
il a été assassiné par une conspiration
entre les états unis la belgique enfin
pelouse l'europe et mêmes même si on va
un peu plus loin deux m'ont dit on reste
un peu l'occident tous ces nationalistes
les nationalistes les plus radicaux
étaient éliminés non pas par la russie
mais par la france j que le côté
occidental et tout ça a continué
également en amérique latine où les
états unis étaient absolument
intraitable avec tous ceux qui
s'éloignent et de l'allier officielle
qui étaient considérés comme des
communistes c'est que ça on sait ce qui
s'est passé au chili entre autres
espèrent donc cette image comme un
nouvel impérialisme tout à fait donc la
russie n'a pas fait partie de ça donc ça
elle c'est son crédit mais yahoo
deuxième chose aussi que lorsque l'on
regarde la duplicité ce concert comme la
duplicité du pays occidentaux deux poids
deux mesures n'est ce pas
lorsqu'on demande on ne veut prendre
disons que la russie est in qui est pas
mettre des missiles à sa frontière où
est que tout le système de sécurité
européen est orientée contre elle on
rappelle aussi que les états unis n'ont
pas du tout apprécié les missiles à cuba
la fameuse crise de la baie des cochons
etc et troisième point aussi c'est cette
histoire de tribunal d'arzew la
juridiction internationale
les américains s'en sont exprime une
alpes et malentendants sein de la région
dans toutes les juridictions groupe
régional en général et la lie
et ce sont exclues de ça c'est très
allègrement qu on est en voie d
africains qui souvent si on victor la
ferme et on a décidé que cette finale
qui est là pour répondre aux africains
que ce drapeau qu'il ya un contentieux
historique et très très large et qui va
au-delà de la simple période coloniale
se dire et qui dirait a des
ramifications
aujourd'hui c'est à dire c'est la
politique l'ordre international
aujourd'hui que contestent les russes et
que conteste aussi les lisa frileuse qui
ne seraient pas prêts à mettre fin pour
autant conseil de sécurité qui fait 2
avec quatre autres pays les leaders
exclusif un certain nombre de
délibérations et la nationale 1
détenteurs légaux dans le nucléaire
aujourd'hui au nom ou en tout cas aux
yeux des traités de non-prolifération et
ben voilà ils ont l'art nucléaire et
j'entendais quelqu'un dire que dans le
cas de saddam hussein qui a été si la
bulle si les l'irak a vu l'armé
nucléaire il sera en train de vieillir
tranquillement à bagdad aujourd'hui donc
larmes des clercs évidemment est un
atout du côté semble-t-il dans la
perception erronée de certains
du côté des plus faibles parce que c'est
ça je me souviens que quelqu'un me
disait la russie on la soutient parce
qu'elle est du côté des plus faibles
alors comment ça eh ben elle n'a pas
soutenu l'invasion de la libye par
exemple on vous donne quelques exemples
comme ça mais je crois que la
désillusion viendra
parce que d'abord on va se rendre compte
que la russie n'a pas les moyens de ses
ambitions en a c'est une toute petite
économie on l'a assez dit que son pib
est comparable à celui de l'espagne ou
de l'italie n'est ce pas et que ça n'a
rien à voir avec la chine par exemple du
soft power on l'a vu en france jusqu'à
l'interdiction très récente de recherche
ou des scouts nique à tout à fait eh ben
ça ça rejoint un peu ce qu'on disait au
début que même là même les pays libéraux
comme les pays occidentaux où on peut
s'exprimer librement savent à quel point
l'information ou la propagande est
dangereuse ça qu'ils sont allés jusqu'à
interdire souhaité que ce qui est à même
un une démarche assez rare monique et on
va peut-être y revenir mme virginie herz
mais rappelons tout de même que le coup
d'éclat de marina of ciani kova rappelle
à quel point il est difficile
aujourd'hui d'informer et d'ailleurs les
morts deux journalistes y compris y
compris occidentaux mais pas seulement
il faut le rappeler cinq journalistes
dont deux occidentaux un sons sont morts
dont on l'a appris
deux de nos confrères ces dernières 24
heures en ukraine oui alors ça c'est
c'est les risques de la couverture d'un
conflit c'est à dire qu effectivement
des journalistes sont morts ou qui avez
vous-même couvert un des théâtres de
guerre absolument
il y a aussi tout simplement des civils
aussi qui meurt ça fait malheureusement
partie des risques du métier la question
qui se pose quand même c est ce qu ils
ont été visés à dessein ou est-ce que
c'est entre guillemets un accident donc
il va falloir mener des enquêtes mais
dans tous les pays de deux guerres
effectivement ce risque existe et en
dehors de la guerre on peut aussi
rappeler tout simplement quand aussi des
journalistes ont été assassinés je pense
notamment à anna politovskaïa c'était
maintenant il n'ya en faisant ça déjà
rappelé effectivement ils pointent
informé parfois un danger bah oui il ya
les russes ou des milieux russes ont été
jusqu'à assassiner des journalistes en
afrique par exemple en centrafrique
parce qu'ils aient les inquiéter sur
wagner et les sponsors de wagner qui est
un oligarque commencer eh bien ils ont
été abattus en centrafrique ce conflit
virginia qui va laisser des traces
d'après-vous durablement dans la
capacité qu'a la cave et jusqu'à présent
la russie d'influencer un certain nombre
de consciences ailleurs justement qu'en
russie a certainement maintenant on
connaît pas encore l'issue du conflit
donc forcément oui c'est à dire que
l'issue du conflit va jouer soit en sa
faveur ou pas mais tout à l'heure vous
avez dit effectivement que on risque
même parmi ceux qui sont peut-être
poutine aux filous qui admire ce pays
qui se dressent contre entre guillemets
l'impérialisme américain on risque de
déchanter enfin ces pays là risquent de
déchanter laisser population risque
d'aider et chanter parce que c'est un
régime autocratique avec un homme qui
s'est fait élire au départ mais qui a
concentré de plus en plus de pouvoirs
entre ses mains qui a fait tout pour
pouvoir maintenant être tout simplement
au pouvoir à vie et qui verrouillent
toutes les autres possibilités le
concert de condamnations y compris
l'abstention de certains alliés proches
comme cuba on pense lors du vote à
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
montrent à quel point la russie est
aujourd'hui isolé
d'après-vous marie roger biloa alors ce
qui s'est passé était très intéressant
c'est à dire presque à l'unanimité à
part quelques pays connu comme
l'érythrée presqu'à l'unanimité on a
condamné l'invasion de l'ukraine les
pays africains aussi ont condamné ça là
ils se sont abstenus c'est lorsqu'on
demandait le retrait y voilà ils ont
condamné parce qu'ils savent que c'est
très dangereux ce qui s'est passé tous
les pays africains presque ont des
frontières artificielles dont si on se
met à réclamer des bouts de territoire
parce qu'on a des populations qui
parlent la même langue ou qui sont de la
même ethnie de l'autre côté de la
frontière vous avez un peu vous voyez un
peu ce que ça peut donner donc c'est
très dangereux et si on dit et
j'aimais bien exemple de quelqu'un donné
pour rire et pense exactement au même
c'est que des pays comme le nigeria et
le cameroun qui ont un problème de temps
en temps de frontières quelqu'un peut
ayant un des deux peut décider ben je
jean va y aller parce que j'ai de bonnes
raisons de le faire donc le droit le
droit international protège les plus
faibles et ça beaucoup d'heureux compris
merci marie roger biloa ce sera le mot
de la fin merci également à bien finir
ce qui était avec nous on se retrouve